[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
17e anniversaire de la victoire de 1945
le général de gaulle s'est rendu à
l'étoile pour s'incliner sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu les arts dramatiques qui
passe en ce moment sur le pays font un
niveau plus profond peut être cette
année à cette cérémonie anniversaire la
victoire de la france aujourd'hui est ce
que ce n'est pas une victoire sur
elle-même dans l'union et dans la
confiance
m
on
alger en prévision des anniversaires de
mai avait les mesures de sécurité
renforcées dans une ville sans activité
la gendarmerie mobile multiplient les
patrouilles fouillent en méthodiquement
les rares véhicules en circulation
[Musique]
cependant l'interdiction de stationner
dans certaines artères prises pour
lutter contre les voitures piégées a été
appliquée dans toute sa rigueur 160
automobile en défaut ont été jetés à la
décharge publique où leurs propriétaires
sont venus eux-mêmes les incendier
à marseille plusieurs paquebots déjà
sont arrivés avec à leur bord 300 800 11
cents passagers qui ont quitté l'algérie
des hommes nés en majorité des femmes et
des enfants des musulmans mêler aux
européens
voyages de vacances pour certains mais
pour d'autres ce voyage n'est-il pas
sans retour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour la quinzième fois le cinéma a tenu
ses assises à cannes où le ministre de
l'information monsieur alain peyrefitte
est venu présider la journée de la
presse filmée internationale
[Musique]
à la peine chaque année le cinéma
d'actualité aura donc était aussi à
l'honneur au cours de ce 15ème festival
qui sera le plus long de tous c'est du
reste le prix de la presse filmée qui
devait ouvrir le palmarès
attendons la soupe
[Applaudissements]
pour l'heure la foule ne songe qu'au
vedettes et les cameramen bousculent à
sophia loren et romy schneider leur ont
fourni les premières parmi les plus
réussies sans doute
quant au film 34 sont à la fiche de
cannes un festival chargé
[Musique]
à versailles où l'académie française
s'était transportée en raison des
réparations de la célèbre coupole le
cinéma guidé par marcel achard a été
accueilli de façon très grand siècle
dans l'immortalité l'honorable compagnie
en effet receveur nucléaire qu'elle
compte aujourd'hui parmi les siens aux
côtés de daniel rops jean cocteau et
marcel pagnol
à ceux qui animèrent les premiers
tableaux d'une si vaste féerie et qui
sur les mers de mon métier
à ce plan sont les artisans équipe
rennaise thèmes et moi les déceptions et
les enthousiasmes d'une profession dont
la loi et de faire le mieux possible
pour le plus grand nombre
permettez-moi de dédier une pensée
éternelle au moment où votre compagnie
ben alors arts et lettres de noblesse
c'est en leur nom mes yeux de celui ya
l'honneur de les représenter receipts
aux adresses son remerciement
le suivant la réalisation de son
programme atomique la france a procédé
le 1er mai à une explosion nucléaire
souterraine dans le logar à une centaine
de km au nord de tamanrasset
l'expérience a été conduite dans un
massif granitique au fond d'une galerie
creusée dans la montagne outre son
aspect militaire l'intérêt de ce type
d'essais et de permettre d'envisager des
applications pacifiques des explosifs
nucléaires et d'exclure les risques de
retombées radioactives
et voici l'heure h 3 2 1 0
rendement du sol soulève les poussières
accumulés par l'érosion sans cassure de
la montagne elles ne sont pas
radioactives les émanations son
impermanence contrôler pour déceler tout
danger accidentelle
à l'heure h également d une heure h
retardé depuis quatorze bras les
etats-unis ont lancé un cap canaveral la
première fusée utilisant l'hydrogène
liquide comme carburant monte sur un
premier étage du type atlas cette fusée
nommé senteurs a explosé en vol 50
secondes après son lancement
l'engin aurait dû s'élever à l'altitude
de 500 km et parcourir une distance de
1800 km cet incident amènera peut-être
des retards pour le prochain vol spatial
[Musique]
à l'heure h comment parvenir à ce que
l'alerté soit donnée à temps c'est le
problème qu'ont résolu les ingénieurs
polonais en étant intimement
électronique chimie un liquide se répand
dans un lit muni du dispositif et la
plaque sensible transmet la peine
c'est là un progrès considérable mais à
qui peut-il servir direz vous mais
honneur sauvy bien sûr les grands n'ont
pas de ces oublis du jeune âge
[Musique]
sous le ciel le plus bleu du monde
dans le décor le plus chargé d'histoire
athènes a assisté au plus fastueux
mariage de ces dix dernières années la
princesse sophie filles des souverains
de graisse épousait don juan carlos
prince des asturies héritier du trône
d'espagne
une première cérémonie religieuse se
déroulait à la cathédrale catholique
devant un parterre de rois et de reines
de princes et de princesses où se
retrouvaient vivants les plus beaux noms
du gotha
[Musique]
on
dehors la foule grecque à laquelle se
mêlent et 5000 espagnol exprime est une
allégresse toute méditerranéenne en
applaudissant la descente des 140 mg une
halte est reconnaissante ou rappelé jean
de luxembourg
bernard de hollande
[Musique]
le comte et la comtesse de paris et leur
tri yann de france
la reine frederica de graisse et le
comte de barcelone mon père de don
joueurs
[Applaudissements]
une seconde cérémonie celle là de rite
orthodoxe religion de la famille royale
hélène confirme l union qui allie
aujourd'hui deux dynasties
au bras de son père le roi paul de grèce
la princesse sophie retrouvait don juan
dans la basilique décoré de 30 mille
roses rouges
représentent du primat de grèce assisté
de 24 avec vêtus de brocart se dérouler
les rites sont yeux de la liturgie
orientale riz blé couronne
rip de la danse d'isaïe autour de la
table sacramentelle pluie de pétales
hérite plus familial voici qu'on voit là
même frédéric a lancé au visage des
jeunes mariés deux poignées le pétale
avant de les embrasser
[Musique]
le jeune couple va maintenant ce trident
incarnation au milieu des sonneries de
cloches et des salves d'artillerie et c2
j'envisage touchés par les plats de leur
race et de leur élévation la foule n'en
voit plus que l'éclat de leur bonheur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
atteignent gardera surtout de cette
journée france curieuse le souvenir d'un
sourire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]